Speaker 1: I have another one of these kind
of dystopian stories about my interactions
with the medical system.
Many of you will remember my infamous 35 $40000
appendectomy from a couple of years back.
I have a new one, guys.
I had a freckle removed.
And we're talking about 23, $100, so here's
what what went on I had I have various freckles
and moles, like many people do.
I am not going to list where every single
one of them is, but all sorts of different
places.
And I had one on my abdomen.
It just looked a little bit different.
It had a little bit of a glow around it.
Um, it had like a little black dot.
And what was otherwise a okay.
Well, I don't need to describe to you that
the exact dermatological characteristics,
but I said, I'm going to have this one looked
at.
So I went to my dermatologist and I said to
him, Sir, what do you think?
And he looked at it and he said, it's probably
fine.
Let's put it under a black light.
I forget what that's called, but he did that.
And he said the black light stuff.
It also seems fine.
But you know, we can't really be sure unless
we do a biopsy.
Do you think you want a biopsy?
And I said, Oh boy, I don't know.
I did not big on medical procedures.
What's the biopsy?
He says.
Little shot of numbing.
And then I take this thing called a biopsy
punch looks like a hole punch, and we'll just
punch out a two millimeter little circle will
send it out to be looked at.
And I said, Do you think medically it's appropriate?
He said, Listen, my view is when your attention
goes to a particular freckle or mole.
It might be for a reason.
So we'll get information, let's do it.
I said, fine.
Name me up.
Give me the whole thing.
We did it.
I have a I have a pretty crappy insurance
because as a self-employed individual, I'm
in the private market.
Private market plans are just terrible.
I pay five hundred and forty three dollars
a month and I still have a $60 co-pay for
specialists.
And I still have a $2000 deductible for analysis
of any kind.
So he does the biopsy and I hear back, it's
benign.
It's benign, it's nothing.
Let's just see if it comes back.
We'll keep an eye on it, but it's benign.
No need to worry.
Great.
Well, I know I'm going to get a bill for my
$60 co-pay.
First bill comes in and I'm putting these
up on the screen for you guys.
First bill is for $631.
Whoa, wait, hold.
Where did this come from?
Well, I had in my office visit.
So they charge for that.
I had the biopsy that was $204.
OK.
And then there was the lab pathology that
needed to be done.
You can't just do the biopsy.
You've got to study the biopsy.
So it's one.
Another 159 bucks.
So now it's 31.
My insurance covered about half, leaving $300
for me.
So I've got my $60 co-pay.
But some of this stuff is not part of the
office visit.
It's extra.
So I owed $307 and I thought, OK, well, that's
not that bad.
But wait a second.
What about the facility?
I mean, guys, they've got to keep the lights
on.
The temperature was pleasant in the room,
so I've got to pay for the facility, but also
I need to pay for the procedure itself.
I don't even know what I mean.
I thought I already did.
So that's another 11 $150, but not to worry.
My insurance company has covered $510, leaving
only another 639 for me.
Now you want to know the sick reality before
I total all of this up for you guys.
Part of what the insurance covered.
They didn't actually pay.
It's that my insurance negotiated a discount,
so even though it shows up that my insurance
covered $510 of one piece and $320 of the
other piece, they didn't really cover $800.
More than half of that was they.
Thank God they did this for me.
Aren't they nice?
They negotiated a discount with my insurance
company.
So at the end of the day, a five minute biopsy
ends up with me owing for the month 14 $189.
It's I'm already in for five 43 on my health
insurance and then I owe another $940 for
the biopsy.
Am I better off not having insurance is a
really fair question there.
There's this whole cycle that happens and
we've talked about the broken nature of the
system.
Not everybody pays.
And insurance companies negotiate discounts,
so this creates a race to the bottom, really
a race to the top where the providers keep
bumping up the prices that they build to insurance,
knowing that insurance is going to come to
them and say, we don't want to pay that much.
We want to pay less.
So give us a discount.
And then knowing that some people won't have
insurance and they'll end up not paying at
all, and they'll have to write off some of
that.
So they have to raise the price even more
to account for.
Some people aren't going to pay.
Maybe they really should only be charging
$300 for this total.
But between insurance and medical billing
and overhead and negotiated discounts, it
goes up, up, up, up, up.
So at the end of the day, if I didn't even
have insurance, it's conceivable that I could
have gone to them and said, Guys, do you have
a cash price because I have no insurance?
I would have saved my $540 a month in premium,
and maybe they would have said We will accept
X or we will accept Y or some some smaller
amount.
Obviously, the risk with that is if you have
something really major, $250000, $500000,
you know, ICU stays really, really bad.
Even the cash discount is not going to be
affordable.
So just another.
This is not unique.
This is a very small thing.
I know many of you in the audience have emailed
saying you, you've got hundreds of thousands
of dollars a month in bills because you're
on expensive medications or require expensive
treatments, et cetera.
I am just giving you a tiny little example.
This was the smallest skin biopsy that could
be done the two millimeter.
They call it the little boy.
It wasn't, you know, you don't want to see
the big boy when they have to do the big boy.
And we're talking about total 23:00 dollars,
of which I end up paying nine something.
Plus my health insurance premium.
It's not a sustainable system.
And by the way.
I can afford this right at the end of the
day.
This 9:50, I can afford it.
It's painful.
Yeah, I mean, it's frustrating, but I can
afford it.
Forty percent of the country can't meet an
unexpected $400 expense without going into
debt.
I went in thinking, I have a $60 co-pay when
there.
The doctor says the appropriate thing is to
do a biopsy, but I'm going to say no.
And all of a sudden I come out owing 950.
In addition to my health insurance premium,
it's a crazy system and I know that I will
get emails from people around the country
saying around the world, rather saying, David,
that system in the U.S. is nuts.
We know it's nuts.
Trust me, we know it's nuts.